ignoré des dérèglements climatiques se
succèdent au nord de l'inde les
inondations auraient fait plus de 900
morts aux etats unis l'évacuation de
quelque deux cent mille personnes en
caroline du nord a commencé avant
l'arrivée du cyclone boni divers
organisations internationales disposent
de moyens de haute technologie pour
observer les évolutions climatiques
ainsi l' agence spatiale européenne qui
dispose grâce au satellite d'image très
précise et forte utile pour prévenir
contre l'éventuelle catastrophe
explication patrice pollet aux émeutes
cette image est la plus récente qui ne
soit pas venu de l'espace
elle a été prise par un satellite nous
sommes en chine
voici le fleuve yangtsé et les
inondations submerge le delta les
premières images satellites date des
années 70 le besoin de surveiller la
terre d'en-haut se fait alors sentir
l'espace le lieu idéal pour le satellite
spot qui observe les catastrophes
naturelles indonésie jouer à 97
à droite la rivière banni tout en haut à
gauche les premiers incendies éclatent
un mois plus tard deuxième image la
situation s'aggrave
des milliers d'hectares sont la proie
des flammes
dernière séquence c'est la catastrophe
écologique
on ne voit plus rien trois images qui
explique parfaitement une situation les
informations des satellites valent de
l'or
explosion nucléaire pollution éruptions
volcaniques
tous ces renseignements intéresse
désormais les gouvernements qu'ils
appellent par exemple l' agence spatiale
européenne pour régler une situation
critique
sans ce que la chine avec la station de
pékin est en train de caler le de
données de nos satellites européenne
pour le suivi des inondations sentinelle
de l'espace il surveille la planète
grâce aux satellites on a vu pour la
première fois par exemple le phénomène
el niño réchauffer les côtes d'amérique
du sud